The frontman
of a popular Russian punk band
just spoke out in Moscow
in support of Masha, Moscow.
Now, we've been following Masha story.
You may remember her.
She's 13 years old.
The girl who was sent to an orphanage
after drawing a picture
of the Ukrainian flag at school.
Her father was
then sentenced to two years
in a penal colony.
Because of that,
an anti-war online posts.
And that rock star this weekend
spoke out on stage,
saying even now at this point,
he can no longer stay silent.
I have to feeling
this Masha Moscow yoga case
somehow just won't let me go
Maybe because my daughter
is the same age as her.
She is 14 and Masha is 13.
Because we are friends.
I want to urge you, Google this case
to find out what happened there.
And feel horrified
at what happened to Masha and her family.
Very similar,
I thought, for a drawing
that she made in her art class
Well,
I'm playing here
so you can hear the noises,
what they're chanting there.
The crowd in Russian is f the war.
That's their response.
Matthew Chance is OUTFRONT.
And Matthew,
you have long covered Putin from Moscow
and the crackdown on his opponents.
It seems at
this point is getting even worse.
Yeah,
it seems like it's getting worse, Erin.
You know, almost by the day.
I mean, Vladimir Kara-Murza,
for instance, I've known him for years
and throughout that time,
he has consistently been critical
of the Russian president, Vladimir Putin.
He's sharply condemned the Ukraine war.
He's spoken out against the crackdown
against dissidents as well.
And now it's just incredible to see
that he's been jailed for speaking out
Today,
the whole world sees
what the Putin regime
is doing to Ukraine.
The cluster bombs
on residential areas,
the bombings of maternity wards
and hospitals and schools.
It was this speech
before the Arizona State House
that Russian prosecutors used
as part of their case
against Vladimir Kara-Murza
Russia had launched its invasion
of Ukraine just a few weeks earlier.
And the veteran Kremlin critic,
like so many others, was incensed.
The war crimes, these are war crimes
that are being contested a month later.
Kara-Murza was arrested
in Moscow,
accused of discrediting the Russian army
He was later
also charged
with the much more serious
offense of treason.
This is the latest in court in Moscow.
Kara-Murza stood motionless
as he was sentenced to 25 years in jail
outside.
There was international outcry,
criminalization
of criticism of government action
is a sign of weakness, not strength.
We support the right of Mr.
Kara-Murza and every Russian citizen
to have a voice
in the direction of their country.
More than 40 other foreign diplomats
at the sentencing to while in Britain
where Kara-Murza is a dual citizen.
The Russian ambassador was summoned over
what was called
a politically motivated conviction
It would by no means be Russia's first.
The country's most high profile
opposition figure, Alexei
Navalny is already serving an 11
and a half year sentence
amid renewed concerns
for his health behind bars
when he crossed that.
Another prominent
Russian opposition leader,
Ilya Yashin, was recently sentenced
to eight and a half years in jail
for criticizing the Ukraine war crimes
This will all end soon,
he shouted out in court.
But there's no real reason for optimism.
In fact, the Russian crackdown on free
speech is getting worse,
even though only last month.
US reporter Evan Gudkov,
which of the Wall Street
Journal in Russia was arrested
for espionage?
The paper vehemently denies
the charges against him,
but it also sends a chilling
Kremlin message aimed at silencing
the voices against it.
Well, Erin, tonight
the Russian foreign ministry
is slamming international criticism
of the Kara-Murza case, but criticizing
night states
in particular for meddling
in the internal affairs of Russia.
But the fact it's been sent down
for so long underlines
the lengths
to which the Kremlin will now go to
lock up
and silence
those that it sees as a political threat.
Erin,
Matthew Chance,
thank you very much, live
from Moscow tonight.
OUTFRONT now,
Vladimir Kara-Murza
as defense attorney, Vadim Prokhorov.
And Vadim,
I appreciate your time tonight.
I know you were just with Kara-Murza
ten days ago.
Were you surprised today
by the length of the sentence handed down
so unfortunately,
it was not a great surprise.
It's absolutely ill.
It's just all of these criminal case
just from the beginning
had nothing to do with justice.
It was our lawfully here
initiate the law, properly investigated
and lawfully judged and so on.
And so that has nothing to do
with the law of justice.
But at the same time,
it was also a great surprise
because we had where we thought at all
that was the main goal of the job
of the Board of Justice
was to commit to him
to the maximum
maximum penalty as they can.
It was no surprise for us
about 4000 side.
Absolutely terrible.
Absolutely.
And it's it's a very
surreal,
very, very bright future for Russia.
And so she kept
Vadim a 25 years to many.
I mean, it is
it is impossible
to truly imagine what that means.
How long do you believe
Kara-Murza will actually be in prison?
The problem is that the law is
really unfortunately
because of disease.
As a consequence of
his two poisonous
in 16 and 17.
Everybody knows that
there were two poison
to stone poisoning of Mr.
Graham was
made by a KGB agent,
and his health after that is quite right.
So we worry about him.
So we worry about his
life.
It's a question of life and death.
And in fact,
ultimately it's a death penalty.
Vadim,
I know you've spent
a lot of time with him.
You were with him,
as I mentioned, just ten days ago.
And I know
you've been spending time
with his wife, Yevgenia today.
Obviously, they have three children.
She's she's now raising them alone.
How is she doing?
So I think it's better to ask
Vladimir the main than the main idea
is to see
Bill after he's
his beloved spouse and his children.
Most of his dreams,
most of his thoughts are about this.
And when they visited him in Jordan,
they lost
You're in the Moscow
pretrial detention center.
We also on the often discussed people,
we often speak with them about his family
and much more.
A couple of days ago, he was the chairman
of the Board of Judges,
which happened to be one of his declined
Tuesday
was to make a call to his three children.
So unfortunately,
I think that
the kind of
psychological pressure,
pressure on building,
but unfortunately,
it's it's really torture.
But thank you so much for taking the time
to share with us everything that you can
in the midst of this thanks.
Thank you.
And OUTFRONT now, the former U.S.
ambassador to Russia, John Sullivan.
He is also a friend
of Vladimir Kara-Murza.
And, Ambassador, I appreciate your time.
25 years for Kara-Murza.
And you heard it.
You heard Vadim, his lawyer,
tell me that
this had nothing to do with justice.
What does this sentence tell you about
Putin's state of mind right now?
Well, thanks, Aaron.
It's great to be with you again.
It says a lot about his state of mind.
In the state of fear and paranoia.
What Vladimir did was speak
truth was criticized
the government and its aggressive
war in Ukraine.
That's in his words, alone.
And he has a 25 year sentence.
If you look at other charges
that the Russian government
has brought
against foreigners,
that they accused of espionage directly
undermining the
national security of Russia,
they they've gotten shorter sentences.
25 years is an extraordinary sentence
for someone exercising
what is supposed to be
is right
in Russia
to speak his mind freely,
which he obviously doesn't have.
Neither he nor
any Russian has that right anymore.
No.
And Kara-Murza
attorney told me,
as you heard,
that unfortunately it's a death penalty.
That's how he sees the 25 year
sentence, given Kara-Murza as health
after those poisonings
that they said he
endured in recent years.
Ambassador, does Kara-Murza
have any chance of being released
while Vladimir Putin is still in power?
I think this sentence in the way
he's been
treated is an indication
of how threatening he is
to President Putin. And to the Kremlin.
The more articulate
he is,
the more courageous
he is, the more threatening he is.
So he's not going to be allowed
to speak freely
while President Putin
and his special military
while he's in office
in a special military
operation is ongoing.